very good morning everybody you're very
welcome to an extended specially
extended breakfast show for you here on
Sky news this morning live from the
Conservative Party Conference in
Birmingham we'll bring you the prime
minister's first ever conference speech
live as the city wakes up to rain and
overcast Skies the question on
everyone's lips is Camilla's trust
brighten the mood the foreign secretary
James cleverley with us very shortly
indeed it is Wednesday the 5th of
October
changing gears the Prime Minister
prepares to defend her economic Planet
Party Conference promising and New
Britain for a new era against a backdrop
of u-turns and accusations of a rebel
coup
missile malfunctioned South Korea and
the U.S carry out Military drills in
response to North Korea's ballistic
missile launch but it doesn't quite go
to plan
on the Move Ukraine's President says his
military has taken back dozens of
Southern Towns over the last week we
report from inside recaptured lemon in
Donetsk
police on the hunt for a potential
serial killer in California released new
CCTV of a person of interest following
six murders
commuter chaos train drivers walk out in
the latest strike overpaid jobs and
conditions will have the union boss on
the show
also coming up on the program for you
this morning live here at Joy Party
Conference in Birmingham
[Music]
we'll be looking ahead to the prime
minister's Maiden conference speech with
a selection of people including the
former conservative party chair that's
Lord pickles the conservative peer
baroness Karen Brady and the labor
Deputy leader of Birmingham Council who
hardly surprisingly some might say is
not happy why not we'll find out
[Music]
foreign
everybody it's not the best start for a
new prime minister a major u-turn on her
economic plans accusations of a rebel
coup party deviser of a benefits policy
markets in turmoil and mortgage misery
for Millions today Liz trust will
attempt to put all of that behind her in
her first ever Party Conference speech
promising a New Britain for a new era
the question is how will Her speech go
down with her MPS here's Joe puck
she seems to be losing control how are
you feeling about the speech prime
minister and today the pressure is on to
show she has the strategy and the steal
to survive I've just got to head off now
to a meeting after chaos caused by
former cabinet ministers at the start of
this conference
now senior figures in government are
publicly rowing I'm very disappointed
that members of our own parliamentary
party uh staged a coup effectively and
undermined the authority of the Prime
Minister I don't think we should be
talking about coups and you know I think
that sort of language is just too
inflammatory and two cabinet ministers
Penny Warden and Robert Buckland have
been freelancing on benefits policy
according for a rise in line with
inflation well I first of all Ian Duncan
Smith knows the pressure of leadership
he argues conservatives want to hear an
economic pitch we don't want recession
we want growth the plan is how you get
there and to leave people feeling quite
rightly that there is a sense now the
Prime Minister has a clear idea where
she wants to go and knows how to get
there while there is still loyalty at
the top prime minister has the full
support of this Conservative Party
Conference and indeed the Parliamentary
party is willing her on others want to
hear more how do you feel as a
conservative member proud
yeah her views on taxation I think
that's come up a lot this week I'd like
to hear her plans to fund it Liz truss
has had a torrid time here this speech
is an opportunity to try and change that
to explain her philosophy unite her
party but it may be too late her first
Leader's address at conservative
conference may also be her last
to add to the Myriad challenges a train
strike is now underway ironic as the
conference slogan is getting Britain
moving Joe Pike Sky News Birmingham
well joined by the foreign secretary
James Cleveland Mr cleverly it's good to
see you thanks so much indeed yesterday
um you had a speech yesterday in the
hall it seemed to go down very well were
you pleased yeah I I have the
opportunity to set out what UK foreign
policy is going to be much of it of
course is continuity support for Ukraine
the indo-pacific Tilt Global Britain but
also it was about making sure that I
reminded everybody about the need for
strategic endurance sticking with the
difficult international issues
particularly our support for Ukraine to
make sure we send the signal that we
can't just be you know uh outweighted
for uh by by our opponent so they can't
just keep uh doing stuff expecting us to
give up we're going to stick with it
particularly our support for Ukraine
that was one of the points I made in the
speech you were referring to naysayers
as well you're saying people in the UK
were you know a little bit down on team
GB but you said when you're traveling a
lot of people on the other side of
events are very positive who in
particular well I uh the the trip I've
just come back from uh I was in Japan I
was in the Republic of Korea I was in
Singapore they are really desperate to
do business with us they want to invest
with us in things like green energy
generation in helping countries skip
Coal Power and move straight to
Renewables defense and security
cooperation there's a real appetite to
work with the UK and these are countries
right on the other side of the planet
and I tell you the same is true in the
Americas in Africa across Europe uh in
the asean region the southeast Asia so
there's a real appetite to work in the
US of America I know the US are very
very keen to continue working with us
had an opportunity well you've got to
remember that America is a is a big and
very complex political environment that
individual states have a lot of autonomy
so doing an overall Federal level trade
deal with America was always going to be
complicated but we are improving trade
relations on things like steel okay
aluminum whiskey beef loads of things
lots to get through there were a few
empty seats in the audience yesterday
when you were giving your speech I was
chatting to people
um people trying to get back to London
and other places because of the rail
strike thought for the rail workers
today well my thought is for the rail
passengers today what I'm saying to the
Striking workers is you've got to
remember there are loads of people not
not necessarily delegates here but I
know in my constituency a lot of people
rely on the trains to get to work and a
lot of the people who get paid only when
they get to work people cleaners and
support staff if they can't get to work
they don't get paid they can't work from
home you can't be a cleaner on a zoom
link so saying get back to work what I'm
saying is these people need to get to
work and the real workers need to help
them get to work by getting back to work
themselves okay okay uh
prime minister yesterday told our Beth
Rigby that she has no regrets she was
some
certainly none that she's expressed to
me she is really really cute terrible
start to the conference uh well look
what we are what we are looking to do is
get growth into the economy I am sure
the prime minister is going to be making
that point in Her speech the chancellor
made at that point when he spoke to
conference it's about getting growth
when you've got growth you can fund the
Public Services you can you can you can
fund the support packages to families
looking to uh uh you know cover their
energy bills and the people that need
our help was ridiculous well look that
program of support and uh um uh growth
plan that the the chance party didn't it
so the so the chancellor put out a
package of growth package which
supported people their energy bills
talks about investment in our road
Network to get the economy really
growing
95 of that was ignored and people were
talking just about before was people
were talking about the 45p tax rate we
wanted to start support well the point I
did support that but the point is I also
recognize that if you've got this
wide-ranging really positive support
package but people are only talking
about 45 you need to get that
distraction out of the way so we can
focus on the energy bill support the
infrastructure support tax cuts for 13
million yeah but it's worth repeating
yeah well 30 million that's an item the
Home Secretary yesterday described uh
back bench moves pushing for that U-turn
as a coup should the Home Secretary be
talking about a coup well the point I've
always so the point I've always made is
when you're in government you have a a
wonderful opportunity to feed your ideas
and thoughts in directly to the Prime
Minister and I think that's when you're
in government that's how you should do
it yeah but should the Prime Minister
should the Home Secretary be talking
about a coup well she chose the words
that she chose the Point I've said what
do you have shares in that word
well the point I'm saying is that when
you're in government you have the
opportunity to feed your ideas straight
into the top of the machine it's always
based on around the cabinet table or in
the meetings the cabinet committee
meetings that we have that's how I
wanted to do it so she would have she
was wrong to say it publicly well it's
as I say she she
um funny enough I haven't actually seen
the complete context of what she said
but the point is my view is anything to
do with policy or the relationship with
other ministers always better to feed
straight into the to the boss okay uh
what about the chancellor saying the
problem
with the mini budget was because of the
trauma of the Queen's death
well I think
you've got to imagine we we stepped into
our new roles prime minister Chancellor
me at foreign secretary
literally within days we had the saddest
news possible which was the passing of a
late Majesty Queen Elizabeth that meant
that all the focus of what we were doing
was shifted onto the funeral
arrangements there were announcements
that he had made which were which were
quite understanding me quite rightly he
went lost in the moment as we focused on
that and a lot of the discussion and
debate that we would normally have about
the support package and that kind of
stuff we weren't able to have because of
the funeral arrangements of her late
Majesty
um so what we now need to do is we need
to lay out and I'm sure the Prime
Minister will be doing that today laying
out what we're doing why we're doing why
growth is so important why we're going
to give support to energy bills and tax
cuts to 30 million people and these
things we now need to get to get the
conversation back on today I want to
come back to that but just let me just
one follow-up on that if I may can you
really blame the death of the queen for
messing up the mini budget no no that's
not they did that's not what that no
that's not that's not what he said the
point we're saying is that when when
when the prime when the uh when her late
Majesty passed away
quite rightly every conversation in the
country pretty much was focused on that
huge and impactful event which of course
meant that we didn't have the normal
discussions they're not blaming anyone
it's just the same way so now you can
think it through properly so now what we
are doing is making sure that they're
very well thought through growth plan
that we've got is fully explained
there's a difference between announcing
it and normally what would happen we
would announce it then we'd do the media
round but explain things we weren't able
to do it wasn't thought through properly
no no it was incredibly well thought
through and the point is it has support
for people trying to pay their bills tax
cuts for millions of workers stimulus
packages for uh that low tax growth low
regulations so we are able to discuss
those things in detail now because quite
rightly the period of mourning was about
focusing on her late majesty and the new
king absolutely right and properly
that's why if it wasn't thought through
properly why not you keep saying that I
did well you know he's talking about the
trauma
it was well thought through it was a
really good package what happened of
course is we weren't able to discuss it
because quite rightly we paused all that
political governmental stuff so we could
focus on the really really sad events of
the funeral of La Manchester okay what
about
what about by Boris Johnson and we were
told by Richard sunuck if he became
prime minister he didn't I don't think
he's actually here at conference this
week that it would be in light the
increase would be in line with inflation
which is about 10 percent uh and
potentially the other option is in line
with uh earnings which is about five and
a half percent which is better well what
we uh of course will do in the normal
time scale that we do these things so we
get the inflation figures out in the
Autumn they've only fairly recently come
out we will then think about all the uh
the the needs of the individuals and the
and the groups uh concerned and we'll be
making announcement in the spring which
is when we make announcement about these
operating or benefits obvious obviously
we recognize obviously recognize that
prices are going up obviously we
recognize that puts pressure on people
particularly those people on benefits
obviously we'll respond to that but
exactly what the operating will be will
be decided
basically uh this year an announce study
part of next year which is the normal
time scale I understand that but I'm
more generally I mean you are a close
friend of Boris Johnson you work with
him uh at uh when he was in London at
City Hall you've worked with him very
closely in dining Street he thought this
through he's a smart man he said in line
with inflation yeah he's not prime
minister anymore he is not so do you
think that he was wrong
well the Prime Minister and the
chancellor have got to make decisions
based on circumstances as they are now
not as they were when Boris was prime
minister that's what they're going to do
they're going to look at these things in
the realm that's what we always do and
the announce the announcements about
various operatings of of of of benefits
will come out in the early part of next
year which is exactly how they they
normally would well I'm not going to do
well I'm not gonna I'm not going to do
the I'm not going to be the chancellor
today at conference because the
chancellor is going to be the chancellor
in the spring when uh that is the as I
say that's the the normal time scale
that we use he is not a prime minister
anymore but he is still an MP he's a
back venture for now there's quite a few
other back benches who are quite
influential not least Michael Gove
um and those back benches have already
caused one U-turn with this government
surely you should be taking into account
what they think to avoid another
embarrassing u-turn
what so what you're describing as a
u-turn
is the smallest element of a really big
and significant support package to
families tax cut to families stimulus
package for the British economy the the
little bit the 45 P was a very very
everything
you guys were constantly talking about
the 45p tax rate which is why we had to
take away so that us guys because you
thought it was the wrong thing us guys
could talk about the uh the the 95 of
that package which was about cutting tax
for Working Families support for people
trying to pay their energy by that point
uh uh giving growth zones
infrastructure investment for transport
which unlocks the growth in the economy
that's what we wanted can I just clarify
with you the only reason that you took
away the 45 P to 40p at decision as part
of that mini budget was because you were
under pressure from the media is that
what you say no what we said was it was
what we said it was a distraction
because that was the only thing you guys
wanted to talk about we weren't able to
talk about the tax cuts for 30 million
working people the growth zones the
support package for people trying to pay
their energy bills the growth plan for
the country that's what we want to talk
about we want to talk about these
positive things if you've got to let you
go you've got to recognize
we do we do that's true but just to
clarify you're saying that if you have
been picked up on 45p that you'd have
slipped that under the carpet and so all
these fat cat millionaires would have
got another 50 000 a year that's just
what you said what your view if your
viewers want to know what I said they
can just re-watch what I said rather
than what you said I said and you know
what hundreds of thousands of people
will be viewing it on Twitter as well so
let's see what they think about it it's
always a pleasure thank you very much
for joining us much appreciated thank
you foreign secretary looking at the
papers for you this morning
um is the papers again Tori open warfare
that's how the eye describes a situation
at the party conference after days of
infighting over tax cut u-turns and
fears for benefit payments leave listro
struggling after just 29 days in charge
the Metro Pictures the PM looking a
little like Bob the Builder and asked
appropriately perhaps can she fix it
the telegraph looks ahead to her keynote
conference speech today with a warning
that things will get worse before they
get better but says it will be worth it
in the end the express also adopts the
building theme ahead of the speech in
Birmingham
the times two leads with Liz truss's
expected comments brace for more change
the headliner
let's hear from Liz trusts should we she
was speaking to our political editor
Beth Rigby and she had absolutely no
shame in performing a u-turn on the
government's plan to scrap the 45p
higher rate of tax
I the 45p wasn't a priority policy and I
listened to people and I think there's
there's absolutely no shame Beth in a
leader listening to people and
responding and that's the kind of person
I am and I've been totally honest and
upfront with people but everything I've
done as prime minister is focused on
helping people get through what is a
very difficult winter
first hello of the morning to Ali
Fortescue good morning good morning uh
you've been here all week what's the
mood been like it's been fascinating I
mean we came into it and we knew that
the backdrop was pretty bleak you know
what was happening with the markets last
week the massive slump in the polls
because actually it's been worse than I
think people thought yeah let's go this
way because other people are live on air
at the moment let's wander down tell me
about where we are so we are in have a
Wonder run have a look at the conference
call you know people setting up their
stalls this is a chance for the party to
sort of pitch themselves setting out
their stall here we're hearing obviously
from you know cabinet ministers the big
moment though today is Liz trust so much
is hanging on this these speeches can
make or break leadership you'll remember
Theresa May yeah let me just refer to
this this is the vehicle that we
actually saw up in Liverpool so they do
tend to do the rounds don't they yeah
this is the Royal Mail trying to get as
many electric vehicles as possible
hopefully 45 000 within the next five
years they do have a little bit of noise
in them apparently so that people can
hear them coming together well there you
go yeah go on sorry so we're not far
from the big Hall and that is going to
be making her speech and so much playing
on it well I will be interested to see
is coming back in the halls I spent
quite a few MPS who for a combination of
being a bit disillusioned and the train
strike so they're not even going to turn
up not sure if you could hit yeah I'm
not sure if you could hear James
cleverley the foreign secretary did you
have any thoughts yeah and I thought it
was fascinating that you was basically
saying it wasn't a U-turn I I think you
know this the 45p cut tax rate was
something that a lot of people think was
the trigger that spooked the market this
was a real RAB out of the Hat moment she
didn't even confer with her cabinet
before that news came out so I think
that was and the chancellor blaming the
death of the queen that was interesting
yeah the foreign secretary yeah he said
well the chancellor blame the death of
the queen and then he was saying and
then he was doubling down right exactly
so we had um James cleverley just uh
basically saying you know there were
discussions were able to be had because
of the death of the queen I mean I'm not
sure that is something that's going to
fly with everyone yeah
yeah so and also his comment about
benefits and whether they would be going
up by 10 which is inflation or five and
a half percent which is real-time wages
uh it was a Boris Johnson Plan he said
Boris Johnson's not the Prime Minister
anymore there's nothing as X as an X is
fascinating hasn't it I mean penny more
than yesterday senior cabinet minister
former rival for the leadership race
saying going out and at odds with what
Liz truss has been hinting at saying
that she thinks that that should happen
that welfare should be raised in line
with inflation so you have Division I
think from the top down and privately
one Cabinet member told me too that they
they think that's the case so I think
this is a divided party and healing that
is going to be really really difficult
today so what happens as far as party
conferences are concerned they travel
around the country they used to be
always by the seaside of course didn't
they not anymore the conservatives have
been they generally go to either
Brighton or here or Manchester so we
thought yesterday we take the
opportunity to have a little bit of a
wander around burning and see what was
going on can you name here we go here's
the quiz early on can you name two
Birmingham bands
should I tell you yes one of them is
UB40 yes and there's another one that
you wouldn't have got called Musical
Youth that was a hit in the 80s uh one
hit wonder and also this one
less than a month ago and this was Liz
truss celebrating her win against Rishi
sunak
foreign
four weeks later she's facing her first
real test in front of the party faithful
as she delivers her maiden speech at
Tori Party Conference
it's been a challenging Journey so far
with more twists and u-turns than
Spaghetti Junction Gravelly Hill is the
Road intersection opened 50 years ago
when Anthony Barber released his
controversial budget seen as an even
bigger giveaway than that of Chancellor
quasi-quarting
[Music]
when this was in the charts unemployment
was the main concern now it's the
economy that's causing sleepless nights
for the government whiskey do you think
benefits should be uprighted in line
with inflation Tory members who made Liz
truss pm and her recalcitrant-backed
benches want to know what she can do to
turn around the party's blink future and
ensure they have a Fighting Chance at
the next election she says that she has
a farm and doesn't care about being
liked so can Liz truss is bullish
approach fend off those rebellious big
pieces around her
the next challenge will be an increase
in benefits will she go with a 10 rise
in line with inflation which is what
many and her party are pressing for or
will she halve that increase and instead
match the average wage
the new pm has much to prove if she's to
support a country with so many
struggling with a choice between Heating
and Heating
[Music]
Hospital
finally left
[Music]
some ear worms for you there this
morning uh coming up joined by the
pollster Sir John Curtis who's told Tory
activists that labor are likely to gain
power
I get the thoughts of Tory Pier Lord
baisy of didkkit ahead of the prime
minister's speech this morning
and just after eight joined by the
former cabinet secretary and former
conservative party chairman the Lord
pickles
foreign
speech live here on Sky News we're
expecting that from around about 11
o'clock this morning these things do
tend to slip a little bit but we are
expecting it around about 11 o'clock and
we have a specially extended breakfast
show for you this morning right up until
the prime minister's speech
meantime let's have a look at some other
news making headlines for you on the
program this morning uh missile by North
Korea this week we told you about that
yesterday didn't we well South Korea and
the US have responded with volleys of
rockets into the Sea of Japan
however the show of force led to an
apology from military Representatives
after a misfire from one of the Rockets
South Korean officials say no injuries
have been reported from the accident
earlier this week North Korea fired what
was believed to be a ballistic missile
over Japan for the first time in five
years
the Ukrainian president zielinski claims
his country's main gains against
Russia's forces by liberating
settlements Russia has declared annexed
while UK Military Intelligence says
Ukraine continues to make progress in
operations along both the northeastern
and Southern fronts Russia moved to
Annex the regions after holding what it
called referenda over several days that
were denounced by Kiev and also the West
the Russian President Vladimir Putin
proclaimed their annexation last Friday
in his nightly address Mr zielinski said
it's only a matter of time until Ukraine
seizes victory
we've got some good news both from the
front line and from The Diplomatic front
first the Ukrainian Army is carrying out
pretty fast and Powerful advance in the
south of our country as part of the
current defense operation
dozens of settlements have already been
liberated from the Russian sham
referendum this week alone in the
cursing region khaki region luhansk
region and the next region all together
our Warriors do not stop and it's only a
matter of time before we oust the
occupier from all our land
well a little later on in the program
you can watch Alex Crawford's special
and the recapturing of layman which is a
battlefield success for Ukraine but one
that's come at a significant cost to
civilians
place in California have released a
video showing a person of interest in
connection with several shootings
believed to be connected
they used ballistic tests to link the
deadly shootings of six men and the
wounding of one woman and say the
repeated crimes meet the definition of a
serial killer there's 125 000 reward for
information leading to an arrest
we don't know what the motive is what we
do believe is that it's it's Mission
oriented right this person's on a
mission
um
just appears to be very fluid and and
intentional
in what that one person or or multiple
people are doing
real passengers are again facing a day
of disruption with another strike taking
place in the long-running dispute
overpay and conditions let's find out
more should we Milena standing by for us
at London Houston which is where we were
supposed to be heading but I don't think
we will today uh hi Milena what's going
on
hi Kay well the station is pretty
desolate we've seen a trickle of
passengers whose strains are unaffected
but mainly huge disruption is expected
because 13 companies drivers from 13
companies are taking part in this
walkout over pay conditions and it is
part of a long-standing dispute unions
saying that the wages are not rising in
line with skyrocketing crisis at a time
of a cost of living crisis on the other
hand the rail companies are saying that
the pandemic has left them with a huge
financial hole that neither the
passengers nor the taxpayer should plug
in their views so reforms are needed
because people are simply not using
their Railways in the same way now the
new transport secretary Anne Marie
trevelyn has met with union bosses she
indicated she can see their point of
view but there is no compromise on the
horizon so we may see these strides
carrying on for months more
okay thank you
also making news for you this morning
the world's richest man you'll remember
Elon Musk has agreed to buy Twitter
after backtracking on the original deal
musk's lawyer says he will pay the 44
billion fee which had been agreed back
in April musk was sued by Twitter in
July for attempting to back out of the
agreement
new court documents describe allegations
from Angelina Jolie about abusive
Behavior by her ex Brad Pitt before they
divorced she claims the actor Shook and
pushed her on a private plane in 2016
and assaulted two of her children the
pit has never been charged and his
Representatives strongly denies the
allegations
a famine could be declared in Somalia
within weeks affecting hundreds of
thousands of people in the country's
worst drought hit areas it would be a
rare declaration and a sign of the dire
consequences from the worst strike the
Horn of Africa has seen in decades the
United Nations has said thousands of
people have already died with half a
million more at risk
to California now where things got a
little wild at school where animal
services were called in to remove a
coyote
from a bathroom blessed terrified the
frightened pup had scurried into a
cubicle before it was captured and then
safely released far away from the campus
and off he goes coming up joined by the
pollster John Curtis who's told Tory
activists that labor are likely to gain
power as they grow their pole lead not
to come
hello again everybody welcome back to
Conservative Party Conference here in
Birmingham today it's the maiden speech
by the new prime minister around about
11 o'clock specially at extended
breakfast show for you to bring that to
you stay tuned for all the coverage
you've already missed the France
Secretary of you've only just joined us
James Cleveland of course he told me
they weren't able to have the discussion
and debate about the budget that they
would have liked because of the Queen's
death and said that the government's tax
reversal was only on a tiny part of the
overall support package
when her late Majesty passed away
quite rightly every conversation in the
country pretty much was focused on that
huge and impactful event which of course
meant that we didn't have the normal
discussions they're not blaming anyone
it's just the same time so now you can
think it through properly so now what we
are doing is making sure that they're
very well thought through growth plan
that we've got is fully explained what
you're describing as a u-turn
is the smallest element of a really big
and significant support package to
families tax cut to families stimulus
package for the British economy the the
little bit the 45 P was a very very
small page
as I've said as I've said in the country
guys you guys were constantly talking
about the 45p tax rate which is why we
had to take it away
media's fault now the Party Conference
here in Birmingham comes with a backdrop
of the conservatives trailing labor by
double digits at least in the polls one
survey last week put them 33 points
behind the opposition joining us now to
discuss this further
um is Sir John Curtis he's professor of
politics at the University of
strathclyde hello to you sir John thank
you for joining us on the program this
morning
um is this government toast
all of the ingredients for electrical
defeat are in place
the question is whether or not in the
end they are combined and put into the
oven and thereby baked into the memories
and perceptions of Voters so let me
explain
um we've now got on average across 10
opinion polls a 25 point lead
for the labor party in the polls that
represents no less than an eight percent
swing from conservative to labor since
the announcement of the fiscal statement
last Friday week that is comparable to
the swing that happened in September
1992 in the wake of black Wednesday
which was the last time that a
conservative Administration got into
trouble with the financial markets then
the spring was seven and a half percent
though by the way only after a month had
elapsed the second thing that happened
in the wake of black Wednesday an event
from which that conservative government
never recovered electorally is a serious
damage to the conservative's reputation
for economic competence before the
fiscal statement it was already the case
that labor and conservative were neck
and neck on that Criterion in most polls
but now the polls have almost labor
party around 40 percent of people are
thinking it's best on the economy and
only around 20 for the conservatives and
the third element that's in place is
serious damage to the popularity of the
Prime Minister that's what happened to
John Major in 1992 in the case of Liz
truss across the piece of all the polls
her level of unpopularity you know minus
30 something or other is comparable to
the level of unpopularity that Boris
Johnson was suffering uh just before he
was brought down as prime minister so
you put those three things together The
crucial question now is is this simply a
short-term reaction which Perhaps it is
or have voters been so discomforted and
unsettled not simply by the settlement
itself a lot of this movement has
occurred in the wake of the reaction in
the financial markets does the site of a
government apparently being criticized
not able to have the control of the
markets is that site going to be
something that voters remember I and not
forget between now and 2024
the thing is Professor when people turn
the street and ask which way they're
going to vote they potentially say
something very different to when they
get into the polling booth and they've
got their pen in their hand how do you
bake that in when it comes to being
pollsters
um I okay I think no that's a a
long-standing journalist claim for which
there isn't a great deal of of honest
truth the polls are not always right it
immediately acknowledge that they
weren't writing 2015 or in 2017 although
the errors were in opposite directions
so they were pretty good in 2019. in any
case even if you think you know the
polls are biased in One Direction or
another unless you think that bias has
been introduced during the course of the
last 10 days what you do need to bear in
mind is that all of the polls show this
very very substantial movement so we can
argue about the level but you've got to
come up with a very complicated Theory
indeed to explain why all of a sudden
what was a nine point labor lead is now
a 25 Point labor lead as the result of
Voters not being honest with the
positives I would suggest to you that
that thesis does not have any obvious
credibility and that the conservative
party has to realize accept and try to
work out how he gets around the fact
that it is now in deep deep electoral
travel far deeper trouble than it's been
at any point since 2010.
um a final thought before I let you go
can what can Liz truss say today do you
think in order to make an impact on the
polls over the coming days
well one big problem that she simply has
leave aside the question of whether or
not voters buy into her mission of a
small state and less regulation about
which there's quite a lot of Doubt is
that the other thing is coming out of
something that J.L Johnson's polls done
here just ask people what do they think
about Liz truss and the dominant word
that's coming across at the moment is
incompetence she needs at least to put
in a good rhetorical performance to at
least begin to persuade voters that she
looks and sounds like a prime minister
not sure how much success you will
necessarily persuade them in the short
run about how things have been handled
in the last 10 days but at least she can
begin to look like a prime minister then
perhaps voters might begin to believe
that she could be one
okay it's good to take the time to join
us this morning Professor thank you
you're welcome
thank you just reminder that we will see
that speech from the prime minister at
around about 11 o'clock this morning so
uh do stay tuned our way especially
extended edition of The Breakfast show
for you here on Sky News live coverage
from around about 11 o'clock her maiden
prime minister's speech Let's see what
she has to say
returning now to the war in Ukraine
where president zielinski has said his
military has made major rapid advances
against Russian forces a resident of one
newly liberated City in the East has
told Sky News we don't care who's in
control we just want them to stop
shooting
let's have a look in more detail the
city of Lamont is in the province of
danetsk which was illegally annexed by
Vladimir Putin and that was last week
now though Ukrainian soldiers are in
charge our special correspondent and
that's Alex Crawford has been speaking
to some of those who remain
and a warning her report contains images
of dead Russian servicemen from the very
beginning
they were broken and Bloated bodies of
Russian soldiers on the road into Lehman
as we entered
Testament to the Ambush wrought on them
by a Ukrainian Force Bent On retaking
This Town
in amongst the dead we saw minds too the
retreating Army wanted to kill as they
were being pushed back
inside the Strategic eastern city the
battle to reclaim it has left it in
tatters Street after Street has been hit
there are only the symbols of the
occupation left behind and constant
signs of looting with emptied cash
machines and shops including pharmacies
broken into and pillaged
the police station still has its signage
in Russian but the gate has been freshly
painted over with the blue and yellow
colors of the Ukrainian flag just a few
days earlier this is what it looked like
Russian Flags which once flew here have
been burned the landscape's
fast-changing right now and this Victory
came easily the soldiers say
biggest
and here in Lehman
Russians go away
a little shoot
go away the ukrainians insist there's
more of the same to come but how quickly
is an unknown
it's hard to answer this question
because the weather can change but we
hope you'll be fast and we'll see
Russia had used Lehman as a vital
transport Hub its railway lines were key
to supplying its troops in Donetsk one
half of the donbass as well as its
military in the second half lahansk and
they were in control here for months
the two sides had been fighting over it
ever since and it's badly battle scarred
even hospitals weren't spared
the residents who remained here are wary
of just about everything being called
Russian collaborators because they
stayed as well as surviving a fast
approaching winter
every passing military vehicle is
glanced at anxiously the Russian Zed has
a Ukrainian cross now over it what is it
you're worried about are you what fear
you fearful of the ukrainians or you're
fearful of the Russians or both War over
land he says but we've got nothing to
heat our houses no electricity nothing
this whole area according to Vladimir
Putin is now Russia but those we spoke
to said they hadn't voted because of
fighting and they have other more
pressing worries
we don't care who's in control here it
could be the devil she says we just want
them to stop shooting
the town has virtually emptied and those
left have no power no water and have
survived under a barrage of missiles and
Rockets dislodging the Russians has come
at a price but leaving wasn't an option
for these people
foreign
come on
Natalia shows us the shelters they've
been living in dark and cold and about
to get much colder
the Ukrainian police have returned to
their old jobs try to offer some hope
it's just our second day here dimitro
says we can't fix everything at once we
know you need it
they've survived but this war has left
them with barely a life and already the
troops have moved forward to try to
recapture more land whilst they have the
momentum Alex Crawford Sky News in
Lehman in eastern Ukraine
the Prime Minister will today
acknowledge her plans to reshape the
country will cause disruption but insist
their necessary to boost economic growth
with division in the party already
beginning to show however does she have
the support to carry out her plans let's
talk in more detail the former culture
secretary now a conservative peer Lord
vasey hello thank you for joining us on
the program this morning what does she
have to do today to win people over
well it's been a terrible conference
it's been a terrible conference because
of the unforced era of the mini budget
but it's also not been helped by lots of
other
uh senior conservatives uh pitching in
with their own views whether X cabinet
ministers or indeed serving cabinet
ministers so she has to show a great
deal of leadership uh at in her party
speech I'm concerned by some of the
reports I've been reading today in the
newspapers where she's going to talk
about disruption in my view the Great
British public want no more disruption
they're going to face a hugely
disruptive winter without any help from
the politicians but she has to somehow I
think reassure her party there are lots
of people who say that conference speech
is there to talk to the voters but given
the uh terrible events of this
conference she really has to reassure
her party that she's got what it takes
to lead them and also I think uh when
she became prime minister although it's
got a Westminster Village thing that she
didn't include enough Senate supporters
in her cabinet and so on uh it does you
know you do have to unite the Tory party
the Tory party is factionized and she
has to reach out and show uh the whole
whole swathe of her party that she is
going to work with all of them
uh
what does she as far as the conservative
party is concerned what can they take
from this week or conservative party
members what can they take from this
week as successes
uh they can't take any successes from
this week I mean let's not beat about
the bush it's been a terrible conference
it was a mixture of depressing and black
humor what they can take from this week
I guess is that it was a disaster and
they cannot allow things to carry on
like this so they have to get behind
their prime minister there is no
alternative to kind of phrase everybody
loves quoting Margaret batch in the Dory
party 30 years on but there is no
alternative they had to get behind her
and at the same time the Prime Minister
has to meet them halfway she has to I'm
afraid potentially curb her radicalism
she's got an election to win in 18
months time and she has to be more
inclusive so the two sides as it were
have to be somewhere in the middle so
all they can take from this conference
is that it's been a disaster and they
can't let it happen again
okay
um can they win the next election
yes I think they can win the next
election for me what what will win them
the Tories the election will be how on
Earth we get through this winter if this
government can show that it's not going
to make any more mistakes that it will
be as it were by the side of the voter
as we struggle with our energy bills
Rising mortgage rates Rising food prices
at extremely unstable International
situation if we can get through to the
spring relatively unscathed and the
government can show it's played an
active part in getting us there I think
the voters will give the Prime Minister
and indeed the Tory party
um a second chance I always thought for
example that Boris Johnson would
probably beat kirst armor because I I
didn't think Kia Stormer had made the
connection with the voters I think at
the moment we are hand potentially
handing him the election on a plate if
we do things right in the next few
months we can take that plate back
okay it's good to talk to you my Lord
thank you so much for taking the time to
join us thank you on our way um with
just coming this way a little bit um on
our way again to the Falklands stand I
think James Cleveland was there
yesterday yeah I think he was Liz truss
was also in here she was by that bus to
sir are you talking about hydrogen and
hydrogen fuel we'll be talking about
that throughout the course of the day
before that though let's bring in Mark
Pollard hi Mark how are you just let him
have this my how I grab hold of that if
you don't mind tell me about your stand
at Falkland Islands and what interest
has been yeah so there's been huge
interest and it's fantastic we um so in
the Falklands we um we're rely on
cross-party support to support our
freedom and rightsoft termination and um
and we we had that 40 years ago when
when our freedom was taken away for us
and uh and we've had great uh great
support from uh politicians and party
members and uh we're at the labor
conference as well so I know we saw you
I'm going to move out of the way and
then our cameraman can just look at the
map of the Falcons just to remind people
it's a long way away but you are still
very proudly British oh absolutely yes
sir one hundred percent British we we
had a referendum back in 2013 when we
asked the question whether people wanted
to retain our status as British overseas
territory and we had a 92 turnout at the
referendum 92 absolutely and 99.8 term
voted to remain as a British overseas
territory so uh so absolutely those
Penguins there I remember penguin Island
playing a very key role in the Falklands
War
absolutely um and the uh so it's the
40th anniversary now as well and um and
uh so so we're here again just um just
reminding people of what the modern
Falklands are and um and and hopefully
spreading them as I remember Bluff Cove
Fitzroy Walker Creek Goose green yeah
goodness or bringing back memories what
happened when the foreign secretary came
to talk to you so he was again very
supportive which is fantastic and um and
the British government for um ever since
uh 1982 have been steadfast in their
support for for our soft determination
and the foreign secretary was uh no
definitely uh repeated that message and
came to our reception as well and spoke
there and uh and and reiterated that
message so uh so I'm sure I got an
invite for that
my apologies I noticed all talk to me um
in more detail about energy and where
you are as far as energy is concerned
are you embracing new energy forms so so
at the moment um about 90 of the rural
areas um the energy is supplied by solar
panels and and wind
um so that's that's a fantastic story
and within the um Stanley the capital
itself we have about a third of our
energy is wind power
um but uh in in energy in general we um
we also have um huge um huge amounts of
uh discovered uh hydrocarbons
um so there's a potential that we could
be part of the um part of the uh you
know the energy issue that UK facing
energy security so uh so the Falklands
could be could be key in that but we'll
see and what are people asking you when
they come and see the start because
obviously it's the focala nails still
has a very warm part in people's hearts
yeah so we get we we get all sorts of
questions from um is that you behind uh
yes it is so I'm speaking in Parliament
there right oh okay yeah um should we
get every question from um from sort of
uh you know why you hear um what are the
uh what other Falcons how does uh how
does the government work um you know how
can I get there it's uh it's fantastic I
mean there's a whole whole range
okay and and as far as the reception is
concerned what sort of reception did you
get here as opposed to I put the labor
party did you get a warm reception in
both absolutely yeah um so my colleague
spoke at the lab party and I got a
chance to speak at this one and
introduce the foreign secretary but um
but we had um the reception here we had
about 450 people come along and uh and
support us so the room was absolutely
packed it was a it was brilliant and
what is it that you need from the Brits
at the moment well I think we're sort of
unlike um 40 years ago we're not coming
and asking for things really it's um I
mean we we absolutely do ask for the um
the support for our right soft
termination and that is one thing that
we we have to we can't we can't um uh
get too relaxed about we we have to
continue There the threat's still there
but we're keen to sort of put the
message forward that we're um a sort of
responsible partner now we're um you
know population at the moment three
thousand two hundred okay yes amazing
amazing and youngsters you managing to
keep youngsters yeah it's it's fantastic
so we send our um sort of 15 16 year
olds away to do sixth form in uh in the
UK and then University as well and they
uh they leave University with no debt
and uh we don't sort of bond them or to
make them choose uh you know we don't
choose their subjects for them in any
way but most of them return which is
fantastic amazing how long will it take
you to get home uh so I'll leave uh I'll
leave tomorrow evening and I'll get home
on Saturday so it's going to take me two
days okay well safe journey safe travels
it's great to talk to you can I just
take that back thank you very much
indeed thanks a lot Ali's still with us
of course they go um Ali let's walk back
this way uh Liz Tross about 11 o'clock
she's going to make her speech listening
to what our guests have been saying
she's got a hill to climb she does say a
mountain I think that's a fair
assessment it is one month exactly since
she became leader of the conservatives
we came into this conference I think
knowing it was going to be difficult but
I mean we've had
basically all that Revolt privately lots
of back benches really furious with the
fact that she hasn't reached out to them
annoyed about the 45p tax cut then we
had the U-turn and we've had privately
cabinet ministers who are annoyed about
the U-turn and who also are waging the
next battle on inflation level rises to
benefits which is something listro has
hinted she doesn't want to see Penny
Morden yesterday came out and said that
she thinks that should happen so this is
an unruly cabinet and I think it's hard
for Liz truss to show that she has you
know has a United Party Ventures like
Michael Gove is straight in there
exactly I mean I think you think
benefits and how much they're going to
go up by is going to be the next big
issue 100 I think you know we've already
seen that play out in the middle of
conference yesterday her first
conference this should be a Victory lap
K she's someone that is a darling of the
party she is in her element at these
sorts of things
um but I think you know these sorts of
speeches can make or break a prime
minister I think the best bet for her
will be getting through it a quick
thought on suela bravaman and the fact
that Jeremy James cleverly had a bit of
a swiper to this morning so yeah you
should have kept it yeah the boss not
yeah publicly and yesterday yeah so she
said she accused about benches of a coup
against the Prime Minister he was
suggesting he doesn't think that's the
right sort of language and I think
privately that is a view shared by a lot
of people okay lovely thanks so much
Cindy